let's switch to the venture side could
you guys have made a bunch of venture
investments as well how are you seeing
the good CEOs or good companies handle
this situation oh you know I've kind of
talked about like this pandemic playbook
we're basically kind of being decisive
and jumping into action early it's way
better than waiting
what do you see those companies doing
right now that walk away and say they're
doing the right thing so I mean so
venture kind of went into this this
cycle of waves right so there's one
which is the pandemic occurred and
venture capitalists sort of view
themselves as the contrarian thinkers
even though they're not and they were
like oh man markets are down it's a
great time to buy or open for business
and any other venture capitalist is
scared right now what an amateur I've
been through cycles this is gonna be
great and I'm gonna be here with you and
then and that was [ __ ] right because
what happened is all of a sudden all
these mostly [ __ ] right because all
of a sudden all these VCS had a handful
of companies in their portfolio who you
have a big enough portfolio someone was
hit really hard you know in some
companies you're gonna see a dip in
sales of 20-30 percent some companies
are gonna have a hard time sort of doing
you know making new sales and will hit
their CRO targets some companies lost
90% of the revenue and ok so for 2 to 3
weeks that's what you're focused on and
it's not that you don't believe yourself
when you say it's good to buy at the
bottom of a market it's just hard to
spend your time giving capital to a new
company when a company on the board of
is in crisis mode so then what you do
that the next week
you know people kept tweeting or
whatever the hell they do and then
people were saying okay well let's look
at our fun how much drive powder do we
have left what percent of our portfolio
companies have a lot of cash what
percent of them don't have a lot of cash
who are our most important fun drivers
and how do we make sure they're okay and
then let's figure out how much cash is
available for everyone else you know one
of the things that happens in venture
capital is usually VCS focus on one
stage it might be a seed stage firm a
series a firm a series be firm whatever
but when you do a round and you expect
some other firm to come in and do the
next round it's usually on the back of
hitting your plan or hitting close to
your planner growing in a world where
people are going to struggle to
like if you're an enterprise software
company and you're making sales it's
probably not gonna be a lot of sales to
be made right a CFO's can be sitting
there being like I can lay off more of
my friends or I can buy this cool thing
and if it's not a cost saving thing
you're not going to get it so there's
not going a lot of growth which means a
lot of these VC funds had to take their
fun and carve out a larger portion than
normal for follow on and inside around
to lead inside around since their
portfolio companies that just means new
names will be printed less right there's
just less room for new deals and so I
think most VC firms have done that now
then there's the stage of going to every
single one of your portfolio companies
and going to like the sort of
generalized plan ok let's go through
every single one of your payables and
figure out what you don't need to pay or
what you can reduce AWS bills probably
reduce those Salesforce bills probably
reduce those G suite bills probably
reduce those landlord rent payments
probably reduce those so you literally
go into your state your credit card
corporate credit card you go into your
bank account you look at every outgoing
wire every outgoing amount and say what
do I not need to pay and what do I need
to pay later and then you for strength
your employees which is sort of the hard
part and you decide you know one if you
had underperformers and companies are
notorious for not being good at laying
people off or firing people who aren't
performing often because they're founded
by new entrepreneurs you don't like
having those conversations you now have
the best excuse ever you know to do that
it's sad as that sounds and then you say
ok so if I if I'm not gonna be able to
raise money for 12 to 24 months how much
capital do I need and you often need to
extend your runway and that might mean
even more layoffs and then you say let
me go to my customer list what percent
of my customers are like in travel I
should assume that none of them are
gonna pay me you know what percent of my
customers are streaming services how do
I lean into those customers but I would
be you know if I was an executive on the
phone with all my key customers trying
to figure out how I can proactively work
with them so those are you know the
basics and then after that every company
is sort of its own snowflake yeah
it's really interesting because I think
there's the two components right you can
grow revenue and you can cut cost but
what we actually will see here is some
companies will suffer pretty drastically
and some companies will actually get
aggressive in steel market share right
and there's simple things like you know
travel and hospitality obviously are
going to suffer for the most part but
then the streaming companies will what
will do well what I wonder is you know
and I've thought through a lot like you
don't see every restaurant struggle for
example right so things like Panera is
selling groceries out of their locations
because it's a way to continue to drive
revenue while they have the locations
open and no one's coming in to actually
dine it or you'll see like a local small
business who says hey you know what we
can't actually have people come in but
we can really ramp up our delivery
business right and kind of go goes
kitchens etc are you seeing kind of that
ingenuity
you know from entrepreneurs or are
people still in the mode of like let me
get a lay of the land and understand
what's happening before I make any rash
decisions I think you know it's it
sounds cool to say wow this is like my
moment to play offense while everyone
else is playing defense I think that's
right
I think the little look if you're an
entrepreneur and you think you're
smarter than a virus you're pretty
[ __ ] cocky so I think having some
humility going into this is important
and you can have a hypothesis that this
is better for your business you know we
have a portfolio company that is in the
sports space and one of their hypotheses
is that because a lot of sports are down
they're actually gonna see an increase
in revenues an increase of the band but
it's still hypothesis and we're not
taking action on - on it until we see
the data to prove that we're right cuz
there's so many things that I couldn't
have predicted like you know okay I
didn't know how I didn't know that
Footwear would be hit harder than
apparel generally you know that seems
like a or or I didn't realize how much
luxury was gonna get hit you know I was
talking to another lender and they were
saying that their lengths yeah their
borrowers are struggling because they
can't lower their prices and because
they lower their prices it takes away
the brand quality right and that you
know people kind of know that but you
get it harder than you expect you know
beauty you know
things like beauty and staples are doing
well I didn't expect podcasts streaming
to be as down as it is compared to music
streaming you know and then you start
thinking about things like okay well 90%
of Spotify revenue is subscriptions not
ad spend like there's all these things
like you just didn't think about before
all this occurred I think in a month and
a half two months from now you'll start
to see data as data starts to prove out
your theses and hypotheses yeah lean
into it but until then have the
hypothesis and know what the data you
would need to see is to go take action
on it but trying to convince yourself
you're the smartest person in the room
right now especially if it's your first
time going through a crisis oh no
doesn't doesn't seem like they'd be
prepared but don't go too early